(electronic music)
- (Greg) Hey Wisecrack, Greg here. Today we’re going
to talk about why you don’t really need to
be afraid of some AI fueled robot with
AK’s for arms coming to snuff you out.
No really: Talk about The Terminator series
tends to center around fears of the coming
robo-pocalypse. You know, the day when a bunch
of roided-up R2D2s finally come for us.
- (Kyle) And it absolutely will
not stop, ever! Until you are dead!
- (Greg) But what if the
Terminator is really warning us
not about some far-fetched apocalypse, but
a more subtle danger that’s already here?
We’ll explain in this Wisecrack edition on the
Terminator series. And, of course, spoilers ahead.
- (Greg) And now, a quick recap. When an AI system
designed to run America’s defense network becomes
self-aware, it decides that the safest course of
action is to nuke the hell out of humanity. And,
honestly, I get it. Anyway, after the mushroom
clouds disperse, a war rages on between man and
machine until the robot army decides to send
a Terminator back in time with one mission:
Kill this perfectly-nice lady, Sarah Conner,
BEFORE she gives birth to the future leader of
the human resistance.But humans from the future
send back their own soldier to protect her,
and the race is on: Who will get to Sarah
Conner firstand change the course of history?
- (Kyle) Come with me if you want to live!
- (Greg) Subsequent films in the
series have given us good Arnold,
bad Arnold and stay-at-home-dad Arnold:
- (Terminator) His name is Mateo. I met his
mother Alysia a few months after I killed John.
- (Greg) But each new installment
revolves around this same basic premise:
An evil AI tries to kill us all and a robo-soldier
goes back in time to try and save us all,
even people who drink hot coffee through straws.
While the sequels have really leaned into the
sci-fi action thing, the original is essentially
a horror film. Like many classic slashers,
it sees a cold-hearted, human-but-not-human
entity stalking relentlessly after what film
scholars call a “Final Girl,” aka the
female character fated to survive all
the villain’s bullshit.Unlike other horror
antagonists, but exactly like Mark Zuckerberg,
the Terminator puts the cold, ruthless precision
of a computer into a human body. It’s creepy as
all hell. This basic juxtaposition, between
humanity and dead-eyed machine-like logic,
is what makes the movie so scary. It also
makes you wonder what Siri’s REALLY capable of.
- (Siri): I could kill you and
they would never find the body.
- (Greg) Personally, that’s way
scarier to me than global nuclear war.
But let’s put killer robots aside. Because
the REAL strength of the series’ commentary
is the way it highlights the subtle dangers
already posed by existing technology.
The original movie was set, and released,
in 1984, at which point our daily lives
had become increasingly automated, and
increasingly reliant on machines. And
it’s this dependence on technology that primes
many of the Terminator’s victims for the kill.
Take Sarah’s roommate,
Ginger. While her boyfriend is being attacked
by a burly android invader, she remains
blissfully unaware thanks to the headphones
blaring those irresistible eighties tunes.
(glass breaking, music in background)
- (Greg) Cut to 2020, and we’re so
dependent on technology that I, for one,
have basically hot glued my
airpods into my ear holes.
And not to sound like a Boomer, but I’d say
that spending most of our lives on screens
often cuts us off from the outside world. And
it’s not just about how you almost got hit by
a car cause you were sexting, either. It’s
also how technology stops working for us.
Throughout the first movie, the communication
technology that the characters rely on
constantly fails them. Phone calls are
missed, voicemails go unchecked and Ginger’s
boyfriend embarrassed himself by launching into
a steamy monologue to his girlfriend’s roommate.
- (Boyfriend) And then... I'll pull
your panties off with my teeth.
- (Sarah) Who is this?
- (Boyfriend) I uh-
- (Greg) Happens to the best of us!
I've been there man, believe me.
And even after the police know that Sarah is
in trouble they still can’t get a hold of her.
- (Officer 1) Call her.
- (Officer 2) I
just called her-
- (Officer 1) Call her again!
- (Greg) And when she tries to call them?
- (Sarah) The police keep transferring me
around. I'm gonna give them another try.
- (Greg) Here, the web of connections that
is our safety net comes unraveled in a time
of real crisis. And that was just in 1984. These
days, if the internet went out, the world would
probably collapse into chaos.Basically, when
so much of our communication takes place from
a distance and is mediated by technology, we’re
left vulnerable in more ways than one.The scene
in which Ginger has sex with her boyfriend without
removing her headphones can even be read as
a comic indication of how technology has come to
interrupt even our most intimate forms of contact.
A study from last year found that 20% of
AirPod users have enjoyed a similar experience,
hopefully while listening to This American Life.
However, the recording that plays out in response
to the police’s unanswered calls
indicates an even deeper problem.
- (Sarah) Hi there...hahaha fooled
you, you’re talking to a machine.
- (Greg) The T-800 tracks Sarah down by
impersonating her mother on the phone,
showing how easily good technology can trick us.
- (Terminator) I love you too sweetheart.
- (Greg) Today, Twitterbots and chatbots alike
are both effective because they give us the
sensation of speaking to a real human being.
Of course, whether they’re being used to rile
us up or calm us down, they elicit an emotional
response, and that response can be exploited.
And this is a fear that becomes more potent
every year. The T-800’s vocal mimicry might
have been sci-fi back in 1984 but it’s
eerily real in the age of Deep Fakes.
- (Fake Buscemi) I don't want to have to say
it because who knows when you're going to run
into these people.
(Crowd laughs)
- (Greg) Just last year, an AI was able to
impersonate Joe Rogan’s voice well enough to
convince listeners they were speaking with
the podcaster himself.At the same time,
visual Deep Fakes are becoming an easy way
to spread very convincing misinformation.
- (Fake Obama) President Trump is a total and
complete dip****. Now see I would never say
these things, at least not in a public address. But!
Someone else would. Someone like... Jordan Peele.
- (Greg) These days, fear of being lulled into
a false sense of security by computer tricks is
very, very real. And Samantha, I don’t care if
you’re actually a 71 year old inmate named Rod,
what we had was special and I’ll never regret
it.And, of course, unlike in 1984, computers are
now integral to the fabric of our daily lives.
This reality was explored in a fun, if not
completely successful sequel from last year,
Terminator: Dark Fate. Once again, the series
tries to warn us about the very real technological
threats we face today, threats Mackenzie Davis’
robot arm can’t possibly protect us from.
Dark Fate puts its hero, Dani, in much the same
position as Sarah and John Connor before her
-aware that a single-minded killing machine is on
her trail and desperate to disappear. Of course,
it’s basically impossible to get off
the grid when the grid is everything.
- (Sarah Connor) Now anyone with a phone is a
walking sensor platform. How every intersection,
every Gas station and 7-11 has cameras? No one
walks through this world without leaving a digital
trail a mile wide.
- (Greg) Throughout the movie, the Rev-9
is able to track its prey by tapping the
huge web of internet-connected devices that
now span the globe.In the original film,
the T-800 happens to be in Sarah’s apartment when
she leaves a voicemail revealing her location.
- (Sarah Connor) Ginger this is
Sarah! Pick up if you're there. I'm
at this place on Pico Boulevard called Tech Noir!
- (Greg) The Rev-9 doesn’t have to rely on such
old-school tricks.Thanks to our smartphones and
other devices, we all leave a Godzilla-sized
digital footprint everywhere we go.While it
may save us from getting stranded like this,
it also makes it impossible to hide. Whether
from facial recognition technology or from
Facebook harvesting our very personal data.
In short, a world in which
computers track our every move
isn’t the stuff of futuristic sci-fi, it’s
a world we, and Dani, are already living in.
- (Dani) Hey!
- (Sarah) Might
as well be wearing a tracking bracelet.
- (Greg) But it's not all stolen personal data
and targeted Facebook ads. The Terminator films
have always centered around the most
terrifying technological risk of all:
what happens when computers are
the ones with the guns?Ooo!
And before you laugh at the thought of your
Roomba pulling a gun on you,consider this:
the Korean border is being patrolled by robotic
sentries equipped with actual machine guns.
Now, to be clear, the manufacturers maintain
that the bots still require human authorization
to fire. So we aren’t yet in a world
with fully-automated death machines,
but things sure seem headed that way. As in
Dark Fate, we’ve witnessed an increasing use
of lethal drones, particularly by the United
States, which moves us further towards a more
mechanized vision of warfare. Recently, the
U.S. agency that researches and develops
emerging warfare technology,announced that it
has successfully tested an autonomous drone swarm.
- (Terminator) It's a far more
effective killing machine.
- Oh, great! That's great.
- (Greg) So, even if we won’t be seeing
anything like a T-800 stomping down the street
any day soon, the military possibilities
of our increasingly advanced computers
should certainly give us pause. Which brings us
back to the real problem with our continued panic
about interconnected networks of murder and
leather-clad killbots: Not only does it freak
us the fuck out, but it also distracts from
the much more concrete dangers we face today.
The world depicted in the Terminator isn’t
coming any time soon. But there are plenty
of potential dystopias we could land in along the
way if we’re not careful. From the privacy threat
you carry around in your pocket to that deep fake
of you cheating on your spouse with their dentist,
the computers which we should be wary of are
already here. But, for all the time it spends
teaching us to be terrified of anything with
wires, the Terminator series always ends on
a hopeful note. Because technological progress is
not preordained – we get to choose what shape the
world of tomorrow will take. Especially if you’re
Elon Musk. Come on, man, don’t f**k this up.
At its core, the Terminator series
is about what technology can do to us
if we’re not careful, and about questioning the
role computers should play in our lives.It’s
great that we can ask Alexa to set a timer
for 4:20 to, um, take our vitamins. It’s
less great when we relinquish all
of our privacy in the process.
So what do you think, Wisecrack? How far is
too far when it comes to computers? Should we
keep pressing forward and hope things turn out
more “Next Generation” than “Judgement Day”?
Or should we be a little more worried
about the Rise of the Machines?
Let us know in the comments. Big
thanks to our patrons for your support.
Terminate that subscribe button and,
as always, thanks for watching. Peace!